my name is claudia wild correct city
pet society initiative csi zürich and
a research charité
university medicine berlin medically
got at the moment model and especially
corona heart and post it just and one
rapidly growing fourth doctor mobile
applications this includes samples apps
for smartphones becomes many as of sex
development spring opportunities and
challenges ballantine's way is panel
discussion and because this topic of
digital isa ziona are as complex
as willi nico partnerbetrieben
university's it is then up to charité
because of mobile applications that is
said and support diagnostics and
facilitate dialogue between the heart
procession  as disappointing 1 corner next to
costa self care interventions is besides
interventions the challenges of field of
the bigger picture and to balance
between the opportunities and this
includes the military frameworks and
innovatively creative
which has to imports reactor identifies
or campari as to devel  op the changing
the joint research contributing to wait